hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und oh weia die Eier unser
Stichwort fürs Kochstudio wir waren es
heute mit dem Thema Ei in seiner
Gesamtheit beschäftigen Liebe
Kochfreunde haben dazu wie es sich für
uns gehört wieder einen Sternekoch
Alfons Schuhbeck vom Kurhaus in Waging
damals
richtig
da und ich werde
alles Dosen Kochshow gekocht wurde zum
Thema Ei es gibt das Sprichwort
Spiegelei kann jeder aber ein gutes wie
schmeckt Video bekommt nur die malwanne
hin und damit herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen Folge wie schmeckt und heute
fragen wir uns wie schmecken die
Eiergerichte aus Tommys Kochshow aus dem
Jahre
1985 ich glaube Tommys Kochshow war nur
ein Teil seiner eigentlichen Sendung
aber ich könnte mich jetzt auch komplett
irren und es war einfach eine ganz
normale Kochshow es kommt mir aber nicht
sofort denn es ist sehr sehr chaotisch
jetzt kochen wir einfach mal mit ihm
Spiegelei kann jeder das ist aber nicht
unser Thema heute sondern es gibt auch
andere Formen von Spiegeleier nämlich
ganz ganz kleine die Wachteleier man
muss also zarte Hände haben habe ich
aber wofür bewachten Ei auf lachsboden
alles klar Spiegeleier ach ja Mike
Krüger warum nicht oder sitzt einer
drücken
das ist jetzt also hier eine
lachsunterlage
[Musik]
und das ist Spargel kommt auch noch aber
ich habe nur den aus dem Glas denn es
ist gerade keine Saison so wie geht's
weiter manchmal ist weg das stört
wirklich
in der Pfanne rumrühren gar kein Problem
okay
[Musik]
was wir jetzt machen ist ein
bauernomelett das läuft jetzt parallel
weil es ganz einfach ist halt stopp wir
machen jetzt erstmal mit dem Lachs
Teller weiter ich kann nicht hundert
Sachen gleichzeitig machen und die sind
mir viel zu chaotisch sie können aber
auch keine Schnitte machen wir dafür
schon also anrichten geht folgendermaßen
man nimmt das Ei aus der Pfanne Stern
kriegen wir nicht glaube ich verliert
obwohl gelbes Ei auf blau Küchenboden
sind auch nicht schlecht aus so guck mal
ist das nicht ein Traum wenn wir noch
nicht sicher ob das ein Traum oder
Albtraum ist
wunderschöner Vergleich toll das sieht
super aus Klasse und nun stellen wir uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten Frage wie
schmeckt ein Wachtelei auf lachsboden
mit spargelkranz ich kann leider nichts
geräuchertes Essen Timo
probieren was darf ich probieren
Wachtelei auf Lachs Boden mit
spargelkran
geil nein doch nein doch richtig lecker
Note ich fand es fantastisch oh mein
Gott okay warum hast du es Markus nicht
oder ich habe das so gerochen und war so
dann habe ich so spannend
ist super lecker okay das einzige was
ich dich probieren lasse weil ich dafür
keine Räucherlachs das ist ein Renner
Leute Timo mag sonst ganz viele Sachen
nicht es ist immer ganz schwierig mit
ihm beim Essen kannst du noch nicht
glauben hat gut angefangen weiter geht's
und jetzt also bauen um letzte
mitschreiben was wir brauchen sind
Kartoffeln die kleinen
Kartoffeln die Kleinen alles klar weiter
und das was mit der Zutatenliste
ich kann das toll ah da ach
kleine Kartoffeln also wie man sie in
jedem Laden kriegt ach die muss ich
vorbereiten und dann machen wir
Röstkartoffeln zum Glück habe ich immer
vorbereitete Röstkartoffeln zu Hause
liegen quatsch ich habe sie gekocht und
dann halbiert und dann gebraten und dann
habt ihr Röstkartoffeln sowie Alfons
gesagt hat nice
[Musik]
den Speck
ich bin gar kein speckfreund und
schweinessig sowieso überhaupt nicht
gerne dafür habe ich aber Bifi in Veggie
gefunden und das kommt dem doch am
nächsten oder und fürs perfekte
speckimitat habe ich sie in Scheibchen
geschnitten und danach einfach
angebraten
und reicht schon mal die Tomaten zu ja
also in dem Fall Tomaten
[Musik]
und jetzt sind Sauerampfer dazu ich bin
so eine schlechte Hausfrau ich habe kein
Sauerampfer gefunden und ich weiß nicht
mal was das ist aber egal nachdem ich
den Speck nachträglich hinzugefügt habe
ist das Bauen Omelett fertig und wir
stellen zum zweiten Mal die
allerwichtigste Frage wie schmeckt das
Bauen Omelett aus Tommys Kochshow aus
1985 erstmal so eine das habe ich noch
nie probiert
Veggie
der Geschmack ist schon ähnlich es fehlt
nur diese knorpelige Konsistenz wo du
nicht genau weißt ist das gerade noch in
deiner Bifi hören Kniescheibe aber
ansonsten
jetzt ein bisschen Ei Kartoffel Bifi und
Tomate alles in 1 so manche mögen ja
nicht wenn das Eigelb noch weich ist ich
mag das sehr gerne aber das Spiegelei
darf kein wappliges weiß oben drauf
haben das ist die Regel groß
schmeckt heute sehr ungewürzt ne die
sagen an keiner Stelle bitte Salz und
fferne Idee zum Frühstück die Macht zu
Frühstück dann macht ihr so viel
Spiegeleier in die Pfanne dann macht ihr
so alles drauf was ihr noch so im
Kühlschrank haben ist das wie so eine
kleine Pizza
jetzt machen wir ein Champagner Rührei
mit Kaviar also die Kombination finde
ich mega fragwürdig
[Musik]
super Champagner
alles klar so weit so gut diese
champagnerei habe ich schon mal sagen
dass wir damit machen
hier ist ein normales Haushalt ich
erkläre schon mal das Schrauben sie oben
den Deckel ab unterhalten dann ein
offenes Ei und jetzt können wir
praktisch dieses Arche hineinfüllen es
geht immer nein
okay das Champagner Rührei hat jetzt
nichts mit dem offenen Ei zu tun wir
machen hier anscheinend noch eine vierte
Sache also Tommy schieß los wir haben
nämlich auch schon gemacht
und den Inhalt verquirt ja
nur bis halb Sendung
ne ja und der Champagner
okay zurück zum champagnerei wir haben
also hier zweifarbigen zweifarbigen
Kaviar habe ich auch Mama du hier ein
Löffel so also das ganze Rührei muss
jetzt auf einen halben Toast passen so
machen die das auch kein Problem
so einmal das rote Rührei einmal der
rote kam hier drüben das wie kleine
Dragonballs und einmal schwarz
schwarzen Kaffee kennen ihn auch so aus
meiner Kindheit und auch dieses Rührei
wurde schon wieder nicht gewürzt aber
hier passt es vielleicht noch mit dem
salzigen Kaviar und jetzt machen die
schon wieder mit diesem halben Ei weiter
wir probieren jetzt erstmal und wir
stellen uns die allerwichtigste Frage
wie schmeckt ein Champagner Rührei mit
Kaviar auf Toast aus Tommys Kochshow aus
1985 dieses Rührei probieren
man schmeckt den Champagner aber
schmeckt jetzt nicht schlecht so
dekadent Leute
ich glaube so stellst du es früher
gemacht
das war so ein Fehler ich hätte das so
zusammen machen soll das so schön eine
Dings aber das ist echt Popcorn Popcorn
Rührei der rote Kabel macht mich fertig
[Musik]
es ist so lecker ich werde es mir nie
wieder machen
ich weiß nicht ob ihr kam mir schon mal
gegessen habt das ist so interessant ja
[Musik]
also ein Ei öffnen Deckel abmachen was
macht man mit dem Inhalt haben
schlagen genau
als nächsten Schritt nehmen Sie das
verquirlte Ei und machen ein bisschen
Trüffel hinein ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass ich Trüffel finde aber hier ist er
der hat jetzt nicht so eine hohe
Qualität aber ein bisschen wird er ja
wohl am Ende schmecken
[Musik]
diesen füllen wir hier in das Ei
und das stellen wir jetzt in den eine
Haube drauf
ab dieser Stelle wird diese Kochshow
schon wieder so chaotisch also wir
nehmen ein Stück Blätterteig schneiden
uns ein Quadrat daraus bestreichen es
mit Ei und legen es auf unser Ei drauf
und dann kommt noch mal für 8 Minuten in
den Ofen und voilà unser letztes Gericht
für heute trüffelei mit Hut na da
stellen wir uns doch wieder der
allerwichtigste Frage wie schmeckt
dieses mmh lecker trüffelei mit Hut aus
Tommys Kochshow
tolle Kruste ah also das ist so ein
bisschen hoch gebacken das ist
richtig gut tschüss
das ist das erste Mal dass ich was bei
mir schmeckt ausgespuckt habe also
entweder ich habe es Maß ich habe es
glaube ich völlig verkocht er hat acht
Minuten gesagt aber nach 8 Minuten war
der Blätterteig noch nicht ganz neu habe
ich gedacht dann lass ich noch ein
bisschen länger drin ich meine die Idee
toll toll super toll nee da reden wir
jetzt nicht mehr drüber da reden wir
jetzt nicht drüber so ich brauche jetzt
erstmal eine Pause von Eiern und dieser
Kochsendung denn das war so chaotisch
dass man kaum mitbekommen hat was die
überhaupt gerade wer was man macht und
ihr könnt jetzt abonnieren in der Zeit
in der ich eine Pause mache gibt dem
Video einen Daumen nach oben um mich zu
unterstützen schreibt bitte gerne in die
Kommentare welche Sendung Kindersendung
fingertips Art attack Dings ihr
irgendwas kennt am besten noch mit Link
aber ich glaube das erlaubt Youtube auch
mir nicht mehr zu links schreibt mir
einfach mal gerne Vorschläge ne bis dann
euer Thomas Gottschalk ich weiß nicht
wie der funktioniert bis dann